Now, the speaking of which this may be one
of the last segments I do about Tulsi gabber.
Okay.
And it's an interesting one.
A Tulsi Gabard gave a ridiculously laughable
interview to cultural critic and arbiter of
big ideas.
Dave Ruben, wherein she accepted Dave Rubin's
ridiculous, right wing framing of questions
uncritically, uh, much the way that many of
the candidates did during the early 2020 democratic
presidential primary debates.
And Tulsi Gabbert has now also started to
attack Elizabeth Warren in ways that are absolutely
ridiculous.
She is also stepping back from Medicare for
all.
So let's look in detail.
Okay.
On NPRs WBUR Tulsa Gabbert was asked about
Medicare for all and she was squirrely.
Once again saying, quote, yes, I support it.
I prefer to call it Medicare choice, where
we are ensuring quality healthcare for all
people, regardless of how little they may
have in their pocket or their bank account,
while maintaining their freedom of choice.
If they've got an employer sponsored plan
or an union sponsored plan that they're happy
with, they should have the opportunity to
do so.
Who's talking about taking away whatever plans
can survive in the market if people want them
at what they will cost if a lot of people
abandon those markets?
This is the Republican framing.
And those are the, these are the right wing
questions at debates that need to be called
out as such.
She's asked do you support Medicare for all?
He says, well, I support choice because I
don't want people having the plans they have
taken away if they like them.
That that's the right wing framing around
this issue.
That the issue is not making private insurance
illegal.
Here's a clip, similar question that was asked.
I also believe like every other developed
country in the world that has universal healthcare,
that there is a role for private insurance
to play for those who want it.
Do you think for those who are embracing taking
away private insurance from people ultimately
is that uh, just strategically, politically,
uh, a nonstarter?
I don't know about the politics of it.
I just think about it from the perspective
of, of people of the people that if all of
a sudden you are taking away their choice,
that's not, that's not a very American thing
in my opinion.
I think our responsibility as leaders is to
meet the challenge and address the problems
that people are facing, that they are suffering
because of big insurance and big pharma's
influence over our health care system for
so long.
How they are profiting on the backs of sick
people.
So let's do our job.
Try to bring down the cost of health care
in this country.
That's exorbitant.
Make sure people can get the quality care
they need and if they still choose that that's
not what they want.
They can go get the private insurance
focusing on.
You shouldn't take away people's choice.
This is Republican framing the debate over
making private insurance illegal is not the
real serious debate.
This is a silly talking point that is being
used by people who want to avoid simply saying
yes, Medicare for all is the way and you know
what?
You don't have to say that.
I would much listen.
I don't agree with Joe Biden's position on
healthcare.
I just, I just think he's wrong.
I don't agree with it, but he's at least being
upfront that he doesn't see Medicare for all
is the path he's telling us.
He wants to play around the fringes.
He wants to tweak Obamacare public option.
He's talking about you.
He's telling us what it is that he supports.
This is the way that people talk about Medicare
for all.
When they want to avoid saying, yes, I'm for
Medicare for all period, or no, I'm actually
against it.
They do this exact language about it.
I don't want to take away people's choices.
Now what's crazy is that there are Tulsi sycophants
who just won't stop accusing anyone who points
out what I'm pointing out here of misrepresenting
her or of being a bad faith person.
This is the exact thing that the Jordan Peterson
sycophants say.
Anytime you critique Jordan Peterson, you
are accused by his followers of misrepresenting
what he said.
And that is exactly what is happening with
the many people who heard what Tulsi said
and realized it's not really making sense.
Uh, and then really lame and also somewhat
funny, she attacked Tulsi.
Did Elizabeth Warren for being unqualified
to be president?
Take a look at this.
So you've been critical of Senator Harris
in the past and even went so far as to question
whether she was prepared to be commander in
chief.
We now see Senator Warren really rising in
the pole.
She's first in a lot of national polls and
several state polls as well.
Early state polls.
Do you believe that she's prepared to be commander
in chief?
I haven't seen much come from her in the way
of what kind of leadership and decision making
that she would bring, uh, to that most important
responsibility that the president, uh, has
as commander in chief.
Uh, and, and just as, as a soldier and an
American.
That's very concerning for me.
So, you know, for voters, I think that's an
important thing to look out for from everyone
who's running for president is what kind of
experience do you have in this area?
What kind of depth and understanding do you
bring to these very nuanced and complex issues
with how the United States is relating with
other countries?
What kind of leadership we are providing in
the world and having the kind of foresight
and judgement that we've seen leaders from
across both party lines have lacked for far
too long that have brought us to this position
where, you know, for, for all three of us,
we've seen our country at war for, uh, the
vast majority of the years that we've been
alive.
What does Tulsi talking about?
And of course, you know, the necessary both
sides have lacked leadership, okay, but in
very different ways that are not even remotely
equal.
So here's the deal.
First and foremost, for Tulsi to attack Elizabeth
Warren and say, Elizabeth Warren is unqualified
to be president.
You could generally say, we need fewer lawyers
and business people and, uh, career politicians
in government.
Instead we need scientists.
And you know what, you could have that general
conversation.
That's a very good conversation to have.
But for Tulsi to say, Warren's not qualified
to the extent that being an elected official
qualifies you.
Tulsi is a member of the house and Warren's
a member of the Senate.
If you zero that out then it's a debate is
Warren's experience with the CFPB, her knowledge
of the law as a law professor, her experience
teaching school Tulsi was in the military
and was a local Hawaii politician.
You can say neither is qualified in the way
that we want presidents to be qualified.
But for Tulsi to say Warren's not qualified
is, is just a joke when she's the one also
running for president.
Right.
But here's the real issue with Tulsa and with
other candidates.
Let's step back a little bit from Tulsi and
make this a bigger thing.
Cause Tulsi is going to be gone soon.
She's got no shot at this thing.
The cults of personality around some candidates
are problematic.
Tulsi Gabbert has a huge cult of personality
around her.
Uh, I've been told, although I've never seen
that there are entire YouTube channels dedicated
merely to doing Tulsi Apple.
Logia depends defending anything she says,
no matter how outrageous I've been told there
are similar channels around, uh, Andrew Yang.
Can you imagine a YouTube channel whose very
existence is just devoted to defending one
candidate?
Like they are sort of heroic or almost a deifying
them in some way.
And I remember back in 2016 there were channels
that popped up like that around Bernie Sanders
and I voted for Bernie Sanders in the 2016
democratic primary but a channel devoted to
defending everything that Bernie Sanders says.
And most of those channels have of course
evaporated since 2016 although some are coming
back.
So the real problem I have with the Tulsi
sycophants and the Bernie or busters, the
people who defend Trump, unfailingly unflinchingly
is that they've seem to have forgotten that
people are just people.
One of the things that hopefully we learn
as we grow up is that everybody is just a
person.
Our parents aren't omnipotent or omniscient,
right?
That that's something you learn as you come
of age.
Our teachers weren't and aren't all knowing.
They're just people and they know about some
stuff, whether you're a Democrat or a Republican.
The praying at the alter of certain candidates
like they are, excuse the phrase, God's gift
to humanity is extremely concerning.
Some politicians know more or less about different
things.
Some are more or less experienced, but they're
all just people.
And I've met enough elected officials to tell
you they really are just people.
They're flawed people, people who may do many
good things and will also mess things up.
And these unflinching cults of personality
from the unconditional devote tees are disturbing
and strange, and they're not the types of
movements I want to have any pardon?
And when people say, David, why aren't you
more strongly saying this is the person that
Progressive's need to support in the democratic
primary?
Uh, I don't see any of these people as, uh,
uh, uh, perfect, hypothetically, uh, in quotes
rather in the sense that a lot of the sycophants
do.
And I have no problem saying, you know, there's
a lot of people here who are pretty good,
some are better than others, and there's no
reason for me to now come out and, and maybe,
uh, sort of unwillingly even participate in
the growth of these cults of personality.
I've told you Bernie and Warren are the most
progressive in my eyes.
They're both flawed.
Uh, and we're, and I'm going to continue following
it, but these cults of personality, these
movements that, that, that are based around
almost deifying a candidate are very, very
concerning to me.
And I want to hear from you what you think
about that.
We're actually going to have a couple of posts
about this on our Instagram page at David
Pakman show.
Follow us there
and follow me on Instagram at David dot Pacman.
I may be picking what could be the last green
pepper of the season
from
my pepper plant later today.